i
[Música]
maratón diplomática del presidente
francés emmanuel bajó tras su reunión
con el presidente ruso vladimir putin
ayer hoy estuvo en kiev y en alemania
para intentar desescalar las tensiones
la postura en común es mantener el dial
hay protestas en buenos aires contra el
acuerdo entre el presidente de alberto
fernández y el fondo monetario
internacional los opositores rechazan la
reestructuración de la deuda que facto y
que el congreso todavía no aprueba
tenemos reporte desde la capital
argentina
y ya se conocen los nominados para la
edición número 94 de los premios oscar
la película the power of the dogs de
netflix es la que más postulaciones
tiene al ser candidata en 12 categorías
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es maría
clara calle y es un placer acompañarlos
y comenzamos en kiev donde el presidente
de manuel majo se reunió con el
mandatario ucraniano volodymyr selenski
un día después de haber viajado a moscú
para dialogar con su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin todo con el objetivo de
disminuir las tensiones entre ambos
países generadas por el despliegue de
tropas rusas en la frontera bajo afirmó
que putin se comprometió a no escalar la
crisis fronteriza aunque el kremlin negó
que haya logrado un acuerdo por lo que
se les quiso sostiene que no confía
escuchemos a los mandatarios
pues quiero
sobre las discusiones sobre aspectos
militares y de seguridad
como dije muy claramente ayer hemos
tenido intercambio con el presidente
putin y él me dijo que no estaría detrás
de ninguna escalada
en general no confío mucho en las
palabras por eso creo que todo político
puede mostrar su apertura con hechos
concretos en nuestro caso esos son pasos
hacia la des escalada de escaladas
para hacer esto según tengo entendido
esta persona está abierta esta persona
tiene posibilidades
lazio chile team 6
a como continuó su gira diplomática en
berlín y allí se reunió con el canciller
alemán olaf scholz y también con el
presidente de polonia andrzej duda el
mandatario francés sostuvo que el deber
de los líderes europeos es evitar la
guerra y alemania respaldó la postura
agregado que el objetivo es mantener la
paz a través de la diplomacia escuchemos
al mandatario francés y seguiremos
actuando en las próximas semanas con
objetivos simples el primero se ha dicho
es evitar la guerra
la paz y la estabilidad del continente
europeo son nuestro tesoro y
consideramos que debemos hacer todo para
preservarlo
fayt una violación de la integridad
territorial y la soberanía de ucrania es
inaceptable y tendrá consecuencias de
gran alcance para rusia política
económica y ciertamente también
geoestratégicamente
y seguimos hablando de tensas relaciones
diplomáticas pero entre malí y francia y
es que el primer ministro yo girl
meigham acusó al presidente de manuel
bajo de haber buscado la división de la
nación africana durante la operación
militar marcan está contra el yihadismo
en su territorio y acusó también a parís
de ser responsable de las sanciones
económicas impuestas al país por parte
de la comunidad económica de estados de
áfrica occidental cedeao nos explica
amal benotman en un contexto de intensas
tensiones entre parís y bamako y frente
a una audiencia de diplomáticos el
primer ministro maliense sobre el maga
culpó a francia de haber buscado la
partición de su país cuando intervino
nueve años atrás contra los avances y
aristas en el norte
recordamos que la intervención militar
francesa después de haber ayudado
inicialmente a repeler a los grupos
terroristas se convirtió en una segunda
fase en una división de facto de malí y
creó un santuario para los terroristas
en sant julià de woods desde que la
comunidad económica de los estados de
áfrica occidental cedeao impuso
sanciones a mali el mes pasado la junta
insiste en la soberanía del territorio
maliense y alega que francia utilizó a
la cedeao como instrumento
de mes y se han decretado medidas
injustas y salvajes con el objetivo
asfixiar a mali de presentarlo como un
paria entre las naciones hermanas con el
objetivo no reconocido e inconfesable a
corto plazo de asfixiar su economía por
su parte francia acusa la junta militar
maliense de retrasar el regreso de los
civiles al poder y de recurrir al grupo
mercenario wagner supuestamente
relacionado con el kremlin para
desestabilizar el país algo que el
presidente ruso niega
ya he dicho que el estado ruso no tiene
ninguna relación con la empresa wagner
lo repito aquí con total transparencia y
sin segundas intenciones
el primer ministro maliense no llegó a
pedir la retirada total de los militares
franceses del territorio pero con el
deterioro de las relaciones y tras la
expulsión la semana pasada del embajador
francés de mali parís afirmó que
revisara el futuro de su presencia en el
país africano vamos a argentina en
buenos aires hay protestas en contra del
acuerdo que alcanzó el gobierno de
alberto fernández con el fondo monetario
internacional para refinanciar la deuda
de más de 40 mil millones de dólares
nuestro corresponsal natalio cosoi nos
cuenta qué pasó hoy
miles de personas marchan hacia la plaza
de mayo en esta convocatoria de
organizaciones y partidos de izquierda
en contra de un eventual acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional a fines de
enero el presidente alberto fernández
dijo que se había alcanzado un principio
de acuerdo con el organismo para
refinanciar unos 44 mil millones de
dólares de deuda que había tomado el ex
presidente mauricio macri esto es porque
el país tiene serias dificultades para
enfrentar los pagos de esa deuda que se
vienen a lo largo de 2022 y en los
próximos años el presidente alberto
fernández dijo que este era el mejor
acuerdo que se podía lograr pero quienes
están aquí no están de acuerdo dicen que
la deuda es ilegítima que no corresponde
pagar la que no hay que pagarla y que un
acuerdo terminaría llevando un ajuste
del estado que impactaría sobre los
sectores más vulnerables de argentina en
todo caso será el congreso de la nación
el que deba decir si aprueba o no un
eventual acuerdo un congreso donde la
izquierda no tiene los suficientes
números como para vetarlo por sí pero si
hay sectores de la coalición gobernante
del frente de todos que se han mostrado
en desacuerdo y no está claro todavía si
lo votarán a favor o en contra
y en canadá el descontento es por las
medidas adoptadas para contener el cob y
19 en ottawa la capital cientos de
camiones restringen el paso en el puente
ambassador en el sentido que conecta
desde eeuu hacia canadá
previamente hablamos con david ramírez
colaborador del convoy de la libertad el
bloque que lidera las manifestaciones
estamos apoyando el convoy primeramente
por la libertad de expresión la libertad
a decidir
primeramente para determinar los
mandatos vaginales los mandatos de
máscaras para que todas las personas
tengan derecho a poder escoger qué es lo
que van a hacer con su cuerpo las
personas no están pidiendo que no sea
contra las vacunas la mayoría de los
camioneros al 90% vacunados están
pidiendo simplemente que terminen los
mandatos y terminen el estado de
emergencia en canadá porque está
afectando a muchas personas tenerlas
bien el ámbito mental emocional familiar
y también laboral
yo david ramírez soy un empresario
también ha afectado las los negocios los
comercios canadiense la economía la
inflación
queremos simplemente que ya pasemos aún
a una segunda etapa lo que se llama la
post pandemia de podamos liberar todo lo
que es las restricciones que se han
hecho durante esos dos años donde los
canadienses han tenido mucha presión
muchos loc downs muchos cierres de
negocios y queremos simplemente que el
gobierno diga ya basta
la academia de artes y ciencias
cinematográficas anunció este martes las
nominaciones a los premios oscar que
este año se celebrarán el 27 de marzo
esto es un poco más tarde de la fecha
habitual debido a la pandemia nuestra
periodista especializada en cultura lea
google nos cuenta desde la redacción de
france 24 sobre las nominaciones y donde
ver las películas
una película definitivamente
destacada sobre el resto es the power of
the dog el poder del perro' y sus dos
denominaciones con este western oscuro y
psicológico en freeze quizás tiene por
fin la oportunidad de ganar su primer
oscar de la mejor película es que esta
edición de los premios oscar está
marcada por la cantidad de obras
nominadas ya disponibles en las
plataformas de vídeo por demanda la
espectacular superproducción jim del
canadiense the universe está en el imax
tal como el biopic o rey richard una
familia ganadora donde will smith
interpreta al padre de las hermanas
tenistas venus y serena williams en a
participios pueden ver todas los sonidos
del silencio
fue en el festival de cine independiente
de sundance del año pasado
netflix encontraran download no mires
arriba la santidad de adam mckay sobre
el cambio climático y su casting de
estrellas mouse trip leonardo dicaprio
jennifer lawrence por nombrar sólo
algunos encina entre las películas
todavía en las salas y las que pueden
descubrir en las plataformas de
streaming pueden prepararse de la mejor
manera posible antes de la ceremonia del
27 de marzo
así llegamos al final de las noticias
sigan con nosotros
[Música]